Shh do you hear that yes it's a quiet
burr box place to aka the silence
starring Sabrina the Teenage Witch and
Nigel from The Devil Wears Prada in this
video we'll be taking a deep dive into
the silences ending and explaining the
monsters in some of the details you may
have missed along the way so hold your
tongue and do what the Reverend tells
you because here we go in order to
understand the ending and how the
Andrews family makes their way to the
refuge we must first see where the
characters started and how they changed
along the way now at first glance you
might think that Ally played by Kiernan
Shipka is the protagonist after all she
narrates the film and is the first
character we see on the screen but the
real protagonist of this story is Hugh
he's the character that undergoes the
most significant change in the beginning
Hugh is weak and a total pushover this
is shown in the scene where he lets a
business colleague max walk all over him
even though the engineering problem
they're having was totally Max's fault
Glenn here provides the perfect foil for
Hugh whereas Hugh is weak and afraid to
stand up for himself
Glenn is strong and doesn't take [ __ ]
from no one he even tells max to cut the
crap why don't you cut the [ __ ] max did
I mention he loves guns Hugh also tells
his son Jude about the first time he met
Glenn he was being picked on by a group
of bullies and Glenn came to save the
day
this is mirrored by Allie who also gets
picked on by a group of bullies at the
beginning when he's told by his wife
Kelly played by aunt Zelda from Sabrina
which if you haven't seen my Sabrina
video go check it out that his daughter
has been picked on yet again he doesn't
do anything about it
he just sighs and continues on whereas
Glenn over here when Ally's in trouble
literally shoots a guy in the leg to
make matters more awkward Jude wants to
be like Glenn because he's strong and
brave not like his timid dad after
Glen's death Jude says he misses uncle
Glenn and so does Hugh Glenn was the
dominant figure willing to take on the
monsters and now he's gone if this
family is gonna survive in this new
harsh world he will need to adapt along
with it and he starts to take steps in
this direction leaving the safety of the
car to create diversions for them to
escape and risking his life to get the
antibiotics for his wife but it's not
really until the end of the film that
Hugh fully embraces his newfound courage
when his daughter is taken by a man
simply known as the Reverend Hugh with
vests flying all around and the
assailants armed with knives tackles the
Reverend in an attempt to save his
daughter he even gets stabbed in the
process but what I think is most
intriguing is how after the Reverend has
been downed Hugh goes back and continues
to whack him in the face over and over
again with the butt of his gun it's
almost as if years of pent rage are
finally being released in this one
cathartic moment the following scenes
show Hugh in his new better self he
leads his family through the forest has
grown a beard which is commonly
associated with being manly and keeps
watch in the night he's come a long way
from the man who was always a follower
like how he always listened to Glendon
followed him in his car follow you even
the type of cars shows this dichotomy
Glen and a big 4x4 while Hugh's in his
minivan Ally doesn't go through as much
change as her father in fact she's
already gone through her change before
the film even begins she tells us that
three years ago she was in a car
accident with her grandparents both of
them died and she lost her hearing she
had to learn sign language and adapt to
a new world this idea of adapting is
echoed in her ending narration she
wonders if the vests will evolve like
she did with her hearing
however with them it would be evolving
to the cold now this final scene is
meant to be hopeful as both Ally and Rob
take down a Vespa however I find it a
little bit concerning the Vespa
successfully laid eggs inside the dead
body of a wolf where there's clearly
snow around is this suggesting that the
vests are getting better at raising
their young and colder climates I guess
we ought to just wait for this silence
bat box place to Jude also has his own
little character arc when he stabs one
of the bad guys mustering the courage to
become more like his hero Glen with a
spear fashioned by his dad I might add
the use of Grandma is also a good
example of a writing technique called
set up and pay off in one of the first
scenes we learned Hugh needs to pick up
her prescriptions then we see her
smoking then an inhaler and of course
her coughing putting these clues
together we can surmise she has some
sort of lung disease perhaps cancer and
that she is dying this comes in handy
later when a they need a lighter and B
she sacrifices herself she's going to
die anyway this just makes her and more
heroic and because of
was properly set up in little clues
throughout the story it doesn't seem
forced both you and Kelly are also
overprotective of their daughter Kelly
never once her driving due to the
accident is suspicious of her boy Rob
and you can even see on her tablet that
she's always checking up on her contrast
this to the end of the film where Ali is
out with Rob taking down vest like a
total badass my guess is that her
parents have eased up a little knowing
their daughter can take care of herself
but before we get into the monsters it's
important to look at some of the major
themes and ideas expressed throughout
this film and a lot of them can be
summed up in the introduction credits
which display quick images of baby's
technology pollution DNA eaten animals
riots and war this contrast between
animal and man nature and Technology is
prevalent throughout the entire film the
vests the creature responsible for this
so-called apocalypse are referred many
times as a plague and infestation
feeding off other living things in order
to survive but who is the real plague
here who are the real animals the intro
suggests that we are we bury our heads
and Technology oblivious to how our
world is changing around us we riot we
kill we start wars how are we any
different than the vests as Ali says at
the end of the movie will we remember
what it is that separates us from them
she says maybe but it will be a question
of whether who will adapt first because
if we keep going the way we're going
we're doomed if we don't change will
perish the film also has a negative view
on technology starting even in the first
scene when Kelly is pissed Jude spends
most of his time playing video games in
today's modern age we've simultaneously
become more connected and disconnected
we give more value to our screens than
to each other the release of the vests
forces the Andrews family to be without
technology for much of the film to rely
on the bare essentials
Ali briefly discusses the loss of
Technology when she tells her dad about
the gray what people are calling an
expanse completely devoid of power and
satellite signal Hugh says it's like
we're back in the dark ages we'll come
back to that point in a bit but now
let's talk about the vests themselves
the beginning of the film sees a group
of cavers digging into the rock wall of
an uncharted cave system in Pennsylvania
1,000 feet beneath the Appalachian Trail
they unearth thousands of
bat-like creatures who have managed to
stay alive for possibly hundreds of
thousands of years they've evolved in
such a way as to see through sound after
being unleashed the vests caused havoc
on the world having to adapt quickly to
their new environment they use human and
animal bodies to carry the eggs of their
children which quickly spawn new
offspring the most scientific
explanation of the vests we get is when
Ali reads an article from science
insider written by dr. JP leader which
states the word vests come from the
spanish word for wasp avispa he says
they are bat like malicious prehistoric
flying reptiles that swarm like wasp an
attack like piranha these carnivores act
purely on survival instinct they hunt in
giant packs spreading like a deadly
plague he goes on to state that it's
currently unknown how they reproduce but
several ranchers have reported them
laying their young in the husks of their
cattle and we see this later on
particularly in the scene where Ally and
Hugh uncover the offspring inside the
dead bodies at the drug store the
introduction of the vest also causes a
stir amongst the religious community
with many calling it the apocalypse or
end of days on her tablet there is even
an article about religious extremists
breeding vests in order to usher in the
apocalypse which is seen as a sign from
God the article at the bottom reads we
are the plague vests are the cure this
use of the word plague which is brought
up at least a dozen times throughout the
film is not coincidental and when Hugh
said the event makes him think of the
dark ages I can't help but think of
another plague that happened at that
time the bubonic a ka the Black Death
the Black Death killed a third of the
European population at the time and the
result caused renewed religious
fanaticism with doctors and governments
at the time unable to explain what
caused the plague many turned to
religion for an answer
believing the epidemic was punishment by
God for their sins with the cure only
obtainable through salvation and winning
God's forgiveness the church sign here
reads will suffering ever end who is
really in control
join us and survive it's almost as if
they are saying they have the answers
like their religious leaders back in the
day thought they had the answers oh and
it's wheelchair accessible many
parallels also occur between the Black
Plague vest and religion most notably
through the character the Reverend and
his flock called the hushed hushed
meaning to be
and silent and also because they cut
their friggin tongues out he asks if you
and Ali want to join in Ali's like he's
weird he then shows a passage from Psalm
chapter 3 verse 8 from the Lord comes
deliverance and if you were to read the
two verses that actually come before it
it gets a whole lot creepier they read I
will not fear though tens of thousands
assail me on every side perhaps the best
arise Lord deliver me my god
strike all my enemies on the jaw break
the teeth of the wicked and guess whose
teeth and jaw luckily get broken at the
end of the movie the hush derived this
time of the cottage and asked you and
the family to join them to follow their
example and when Hugh says to leave them
alone we get this creepy message the
girl is fertile fertile fertile Hugh
moves from his flaw of being weak and
timid by getting out his shotgun but it
becomes a stalemate since if he were to
shoot it it would unleash the vests a
factor Reverend full well know since he
smiles when he sees the gun pointed at
him the hush leave and that night we get
our first mention of the refuge rob is
making his way up there and wants Ali to
come since Vespers can't handle the cold
it's the perfect place for survivors but
the hush plant a Trojan horse in the
form of a young girl strapped with cell
phones which alert the vests which is
kind of silly if you're the hush since
we know they want the young fertile
women why potentially sacrifice both
this young girl and Ali plus others just
to get her doesn't make any sense but
hey that's a Netflix [ __ ] for you and
as we all know Hugh and the fam band
together to stop the flock once and for
all
saving Ali and eventually making their
way to the refuge a mountain top solar
powered haven for their survivors most
likely in Canada or far north in the
United States and the family must have
traveled a long distance because there
aren't any mountains like this in New
Jersey so that's my take on the silence
but I want to hear what you guys thought
in the comments below make sure to smash
that like button but quietly because we
don't want to alert the bests and
subscribe because I have more videos
deep dives and breakdowns on the way you
can also follow me on twitter at think
story whitey until next time remember
daddy loves you very much